[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALIK ASGHAR NAEEM: City
regions in developing countries
are experiencing
tremendous urbanization
that contributes to
sprawled development,
a daunting challenge posing
a threat to sustainable
urban growth.
Take the example of Malaysia.
Nearly 73% of its
total population
lives in cities, making it one
of the most urbanized countries
in Southeast Asia.
The Kuala Lumpur
metropolitan region
witnessed a higher rate of
increase in its physical area
than that of its population
over a period of 20 years.
During that time, the population
approximately doubled,
but the area increased
by two and 1/2 times.
Urban sprawl is characterized
by an inefficient use
of land resources.
For example, building
low-density housing
and commercial
buildings will lead
to the horizontal expansion
or sprawl of the city.
Look at the example of two
cities-- Atlanta, the capital
of the US state of Georgia,
and Barcelona, the capital
of Catalan in Spain.
The same number
of people resides
in each of these cities, but
the built-up area for Atlanta
is about 26 times greater
than that of Barcelona.
This is a typical
illustration of sprawl
versus compact development.
Urban sprawl leads to the
depletion of green area
on the urban periphery.
It also contributes to lengthier
commutes and higher energy
consumption for commuting.
It makes public transport
financially unfeasible,
which leads to an enormous
increase in private car
ownership.
This trend results
in traffic congestion
and increased pollution
due to vehicular emissions.
Limiting urban
sprawl is, therefore,
key to reducing
greenhouse gas emissions
and increasing the overall
environmental sustainability
of a city.
Compact development is a helpful
response to urban sprawl.
Let's discuss the concept
of compact development.
The prominent features
of compact development
include mixed land use,
well-developed public
transportation infrastructure,
efficient use of land,
and strict controls
on development
outside city boundaries.
Now I'll explain
these three features
of compact development.
Mixed land use-- mixed
land-use development
means placing
residential, commercial,
and recreational uses in close
proximity to one another.
This promotes walking,
biking, and helps
reduce commuting for
a number of people
who find their workplace
nearby in the neighborhood.
Emphasis on public
transportation--
the most important feature
of compact development
is having efficient rail
and bus-based public
transportation.
This helps reduce
private car ownership.
The concept of
transit-oriented development
promotes having reasonably
dense development surrounding
mass transit stations
as a desirable feature
of a compact city.
This kind of development
provides easy and efficient
access to transport facilities
for residents and workers.
It can also increase
ridership and help
make public transport
financially viable.
It ultimately leads to
less energy consumption
and less pollution.
Efficient use of land
resources and control
on development outside
the city boundary--
single-story
buildings interspersed
with patches of undeveloped land
wastes precious land resources.
Such development patterns also
contribute to urban sprawl
by creating more demand for
development on green fields
on the outskirts of cities.
Compact development,
in contrast,
uses land more efficiently by
having high-rise buildings that
can accommodate more people
and by developing vacant land.
Demarcation of city
growth boundaries
also helps promote
compact development,
thereby optimizing the
utilization of available land
within the boundary.
Planning departments
in KL Metropolitan
are committed to achieving
compact urban development.
Provision of efficient
public transport,
therefore, is a top priority.
Heavy investments in
mass transit systems
have already been made to
increase the public transport
ridership rate from the current
20% to 50% by the year 2030.
The rail-based public transport
system in KL Metropolitan
came into operation about
20 years ago, in 1996,
and has expanded incrementally.
The central area of the city is
served by a light rail transit
system and KL Monorail.
Together, they provide
approximately 60 kilometers
of rail network.
A commuter train, namely KTM
Komuter, on the other hand,
makes the city core accessible
for suburban areas of the KL
metropolitan area.
Similarly, a dedicated
express train
connects the city center to
the KL International Airport.
The mass rapid transit
system started in 2011.
Once completed, it will comprise
of three rail lines connecting
suburban areas in the greater
KL to the federal territory.
The first line to be
completed in two years
will serve a population of about
one and 1/2 million people.
A single train on the line with
a maximum capacity of 1,200
passengers can replace 12 buses,
or approximately 700 cars.
In addition to improving its
rail-based public transport,
KL is also increasing the
share of public buses.
Five bus express transit routes
are currently in operation
to reduce travel time from
outer areas to city center.
Moreover, a comprehensive
bus rapid transit plan
with dedicated
bus lanes has also
been proposed to make buses
a fast and efficient mode
of public transportation.
Kuala Lumpur's city
government has also
started to pay more attention
to transit-oriented development
and, as a first step, has a
identified nearly 70 Transit
Planning Zones.
What is a Transit Planning Zone?
It is an area of 250 meter
radius around a mass transit
station.
Its development is characterized
by high building density
along with mixed land uses.
The work on
intensification of land use
by replacing the single-story
buildings with high-rise ones
and having mixed land use is
in progress in the identified
Transit Planning Zones.
Usually, the city center
is the focal point
of most economic activities.
The use of precious
land in this area
needs to be intensified
in order to make room
for increased demand
for new residential
and commercial development.
Therefore, vacant and
other inefficiently
used land parcels needs to be
identified in order to convert
them to productive uses.
The KL city government,
for example,
created an inventory
that identified
821 hectares of vacant and
abandoned land in the city core
and surrounding area that
can now be used efficiently.
In addition, it
is also replacing
single-story buildings
with multi-story ones.
Similarly, due
attention is being
paid to rehabilitation
of historical buildings
and public open spaces.
Central Market, Petaling
Street, and Masjid Jamek
are some of the examples
of rehabilitated areas
This effort promotes walking
and makes the city center
a more attractive
and livable place.
So how can city governments
in developing countries,
such as Malaysia, encourage
compact development
and tackle the issue
of urban sprawl?
Here are some of the key
strategies to be adopted.
Strategy number one--
urban planning authorities
in the metropolitan
region should establish
growth boundaries
for their cities,
and development should be
allowed only within the city
boundary to intensify
development and use
land more efficiently.
Strategy number two-- the
proposed policies of one agency
need to be planned
and implemented
in coordination with the
relevant federal, state,
and local government
departments.
The 2006 National Urban
Policy of Malaysia
emphasized the need for setting
urban growth limits for each
of its cities and towns.
However, this has yet to
be translated into practice
because of lack of
implementation of policies
by the concerned state and
local level planning agencies.
Strategy number
three-- the practice
of building new
expressways should
be discouraged as it promotes
sprawl along the highways.
Instead, heavy
investment should be
made in intracity and
inter-region rail services that
help control sprawl and
make compact development
sustainable.
Similarly, increased taxes
on new cars, parking fees,
and a road user tax for cars
entering the city center
could help reduce the increase
in private vehicle ownership.
Regulating measures such as
a ban on single occupancy
cars in the city
center could be used
to avoid traffic congestion
and discourage car ownership.
Strategy number four-- special
measures discussed earlier
also need to be complemented
by incentives, fees,
and regulatory policies.
Incentives could be provided
for mixed-use development,
multi-story buildings,
and for the preservation
of historic buildings.
However, along with
increasing building density,
utmost attention
needs to be paid
to provision of sufficient
public open spaces and parks
with equal distribution
within the city.
It also needs to be ensured
that open space and public park
facilities should be accessible
to all residents of the city
within walking distance in
order to make cities attractive
and livable places.
In conclusion, urban sprawl
is an undesirable phenomenon
taking place in
most of the cities,
especially in
developing countries.
It is a threat to
sustainable development
as it causes a number
of problems in cities.
The blight of urban
sprawl can be controlled
by pursuing a compact
development approach that leads
to making cities sustainable.
[MUSIC PLAYING]